>> I believe I did. So is the first frog dead or alive? I can't imagine you
eating a frog and the frog staying alive, so I'm going to say the frog is dead.
Where is the frog if you ate it? It's probably in your stomach.
And are you happy or sad? I don't know if you like to eat frogs, but
I'm going to assume that you do. So I'm going to assume that you are happy.
Thank you, David. So David just did common sense reasoning.
There was nothing in this input which said whether the frog was dead or alive.
There was nothing in the sentence which said Ashok was happy or sad. But David
made sensible inferences. I will discuss a lot more about common sense reasoning
a little bit later. For now, I want to talk about the knowledge representation
called Frames that will allow us to make some inferences of this kind.